ciao ragazzi ben tornato nella puntata
di cucina buttata oggi faremo schifo
stanchi di aver fatto ricette su ricette
che partivano bene finivano male
vogliamo subito iniziare con una ricetta
che parte malissimo
stiamo parlando della carbonara di
gordon ramsay quello che farò oggi sarà
seguire esattamente i suoi passaggi e
alla fine assaggiare quella che per lui
è la grande buona carbonara per farlo
riti lante carbonara di gordon ramsay
avremo bisogno di spaghetti bacon
affette bwv parmigiano funghi a cazzo di
cane piselli lomazzo dl prezzemolo 1 ma
su dl peperoncino olio sale e mio
ranocchio rete picchia o bella vi
ricordo che questa qui è la ricetta che
ha fatto perdere accordo rams il diritto
di mettere piede all'interno dello stato
italiano e soprattutto nel lazio dove
c'è proprio un ingente taglia sulla sua
testa si dice che si possa sparare a
vista qualora l'uomo venisse visto
camminare per strada in questo video
incriminato vediamo gordon ramsay stelle
michelin ristorante in tutto il mondo
che stupra letteralmente la nostra
tradizione insieme alla sorridente
figlia che lo prende in giro io direi di
seguirlo proprio in tutto quello che fa
ciao ragazzi pronti a stuprare la nostra
tradizione insieme a gordon nordhorn
scott gordon è un bambino il quale sta
per dare prima che della carbonara ma
lui sta dicendo che immunitarie si fa
col guanciale questa dicendo da italia
cioè fa dove l'affare con un po di e poi
questo è lo stesso che se
magari capito sbagli una cosa del suo ha
quasi in toto faccio il bando uno
stronzo falsone sprono gordon ramsay con
cui sia uno chef rinomato quindi
sicuramente il piatto avrà un senso a
livello spinario non è una carbonara
cosa vuoi continuare che lui per rendere
più eccitante la carbonara ha visto che
il guanciale non è abbastanza
interessante prende del bacon nota lla
grossolanamente il ragazzo io vi chiedo
scusa mentre quando questo becco in
maniera grossolana mi chiedo perdono i
doveri non ha il passaporto bisogna
restare in italia per lavorare questo
paese mi vengono cacciate mi.mi.sol olio
si eviti già grasso del guanciale o
della co perché mette anche l'olio nord
on
perché se un ingordo ovvio pancetta
mamma mia ma noi alla torta la stella
michelin
dopo che hanno visto stridere ti hanno
detto aggiunta mente a questo punto lui
fa una cosa agghiacciante frenerà gli ne
prende due spicchi pazzano enna melas
taglio cioè è enorme gli toglie la
camicia e poi mi fa questa cosa così a
cuor leggero lo taglio in maniera
sottile lo aggiunge la padella
se ci sono persone armate che vengono a
bussare alla porta lo devo farle
insaporire che fa parte del condimento
non credo che lo faccia per uccidersi
per farla finita butto dentro lacrimando
ci si no
questo c'è un bambino piccolo accanto ai
ragazzi per mostra tagliani funghi per
mano già tagliati e gli aggiungere ma
che cazzo c'entrano i funghi i ragazzi
dopo questa gli hanno tolto accesso
dell'assistito
questa la goccia aggiunge cilindri cenni
non ce l'abbiamo ma prendiamo due
peperoncini l'italiano guarda questo
trito h il salto io ormai lo so fare
anche tu ci hai imparato a cucinare
sentire non sapere superato il tuo
discorso sempre più insulto per quanto
mi riguarda mi dice che hanno peggio di
così lavorava in realtà siccome sto
dicendo sicuramente sarà buono perché
quello è il cambio di champ quella
ammette ingrediente cazzo ed f 1 2 e 3
scusa quanto costa tali dalla finestra
il più possibile le altre un po buttare
la pasta quanto deve stare a basta
ti dico solo che lui a un certo punto
del video per vedere la cultura della
pasta arancia sul soffitto e se rimane
appiccicata in coppa guarda lo farò
sicuramente ogni certo la in quanto
artista della cucina non riprendere una
ricetta è la fatale quale vuole metterci
la tua impronta è pure vero come fai tu
sempre in cucina e non perché rimane le
ricette per ora sei un artista continua
continuate a scuola mi ha convinto poi
se non sbaglio ragazzi potevano sapere
qua sotto esiste anche la carbonara
l'inglese è che è fatta di per sé cosa
importante di ogni tanto prende mette il
sale così sbattendo le uova col povero
bambino di due mesi
scambiamo gli il parmigiano dentro
sarebbe meglio
c'è chi unisce sia parmigiano e pecorino
questa che comunque non mi sento di
criticarlo io preferisco di gran lunga
il pecorino ma dove si fa coi gusti
penati ha due figlie lo sa sti qui da
pecorino vado a incorporare uovo e
formaggio posso dire che mi chiamo
aggiunge la panna da cucina
la panna da cucina madre santa mama mia
questa gravissima potrebbe essere la
cosa più grave terribile terribile
no no ragazzi cile monetizza nel video
una delle palesi youtube e non far
vedere atti di violenza e questo è un
atto di violenza è orribile
io riuscivo nemmeno guardarlo mentre
sbatteva sbatteva sbatteva con la
forchetta in maniera così dolorosa al
contro quel composto indovina cosa gioco
su questo composto sale che non è mai
troppo poco il sale e poi è andato a
dormire con due bombe da 7 litri di
alcol
vediamo di pasta fino in finale la posti
che non ha destato degli spaghetti
mazzate spezza gli spaghetti che andava
sotto casa vero ogni tanto lo fa
prenderci buttiamo un pochino di acqua
di cottura ma sei riuscito a segnare un
composto che fino a fuori grasso c'è
marco cazzola ispa teniamo come lui ma
insomma non proprio come noi aggiungiamo
i piselli piselli eccoli ecco qua e ti
senti come piace un sacco di livelli hai
preso il tuo fratello
la pasta va avanti il condimento ce
l'abbiamo prendiamo il prezzemolo
facciamo un territorio sapete che mette
il prezzemolo a carbonara la mia mamma
si faccia un perito che farà vedere che
io in realtà sono degno diventare
l'erede di gordon ramsay costo di almeno
mi sento come freschezza ma non la trovi
pesante dentro col fornello ancora
acceso si butta luogo
una frittata non spegne lui non lo
spegnersi si fida feriti dati e lo
spegnere lo sai che mi ricorda molto la
sua hai fatto nel disastro un ottimo
lavoro per sé molto dentro vai aver
appreso l'uomo si era preso tutto ho
fatto una fedelissima riproduzione bravo
le ultime bozze di vita ragazzi che gli
da lui in brik e parmigiano sopra ev
alla prima finestra lanci di sotto
sembra quasi invitante che sa quanta
carne fa un botto passaggio a roccone
del re cerco di non contaminati il
piatto enrico non è carbonara ma è un
passaggio assapora la ma io l'avevo
detto che il resto sarà cucinato era
carbonara e la torres come buono già è
assurdo da dire reagan
poi sette chili taglio manco si sentono
rotti o bilanciato scusa per tutto
quello che trovano ragazzi se volete
provare a fare questo piatto non
chiamiamolo carbonara ti prego tagga
temi all'interno delle vostre storie
sono curioso di vedere se vi piace anche
a voi praga secondo me e approvati sì ma
la carbonara di gordon ramsay alla
carbonara mi fa un po male il piatto di
pasta ricordo il rams ea base luogo se
mi è piaciuto questo video iscriviti al
canale altra campana notifiche e
metteteci un like per il coraggio e che
il coraggio porta e paga